Before we start going
off into things outside
of our solar system, I want
to take a few steps back
because I found this neat
picture of the Sun over here.
And the reason why,
at least in my mind,
it's kind of mind blowing
is because at this scale,
the Sun is obviously still
a huge object at this scale.
The Earth would be
roughly-- and this
is an approximation--
roughly that big.
And so for me at least,
this is mind blowing.
Because it's this idea
that our whole planet,
everything could fit into one
of these kind of plasma flares
coming off of the Sun.
And you can only imagine it.
We can't realistically be there.
But if you were in some
type of protected capsule,
what it would be like to be in
this type of an environment.
So I just thought this was
kind of a fascinating concept.
Well, anyway, with
that out of the way,
let's think about
what it means to be
at the boundary of
the solar system.
In the last video, we
explored the Ort Belt.
It started a little under one
light year away from the Sun.
But depending on what
you view as the boundary
of the solar system, it could
be something way farther in
or could be something as far
out of something like the Oort
Cloud.
So the Sun, we see these
things being ejected.
But even in unseen ways,
or unseen particles,
super high energy electrons,
electrons and protons,
are also being
ejected from the Sun
at super high velocities,
400 kilometers per second.
Let me write that down,
And on Earth, we're protected
from these highly energetic
particles because of
Earth's magnetic field.
But if you're on the
surface of the Moon
when the Sun is on
top, and you're not
on the dark side
of the Moon, you'll
have direct contact with these.
And as you can imagine,
it's not the best thing
to hang around in too along.
But the whole reason why I'm
even talking about these, these
charged particles that are
coming out at huge velocities
from the surface
of the Sun, these
are considered the solar wind.
These are the solar wind.
And I'll put "wind' in quotes.
Because it's really
very different
than our traditional
association of a nice breeze.
These are just
charged particles that
are going out at super high
velocities from the Sun.
And I'm even going into
the idea of the solar wind
because to some degree,
they can help us
with one definition of maybe
the limits of the solar system.
And that's the limits of how
far the solar wind is getting
before it kind of
comes in confrontation
with the interstellar medium.
And this right here shows
a depiction of that.
So the Ort Cloud, it
was way-- at least
the edges of the dense part
of it is way outside of this.
As we saw, this is just
where Voyager 1, Voyager 2.
If we wanted the orbit
of Sedna, the close part
would be something over here
and then it would go out.
But the Ort Cloud is
much, much further out.
So if you look at this kind
of view of the solar system
as the extent of the solar wind,
its much smaller than the Ort
Cloud.
But it's still fairly large.
So this is right here.
This heliopause right here--
and I got this from Wikipedia--
this is essentially where
the velocity and the forces
of the solar wind
are counteracted.
That the pressure is so
diluted at this point
that it's counteracted by mainly
the hydrogen and the helium
that's in the interstellar
kind of medium,
that's just kind of out there.
So after this point,
it's not really
being injected out anymore.
There's this kind of pause,
I guess you could say.
And Voyager 1 and
Voyager 2, as I said,
have essentially gotten pretty
close to, people believe,
that pause over there.
And so that's one view of the
edges of the solar system.
There's never going to
be any hard edge to it.
Another view would be something
like the Oort Cloud, the area
where you have the
still objects out there.
And actually we haven't
directly observed
objects in the Ort Cloud.
We think that they
are out there.
And then maybe the most
abstract definition
would be a significant
influence from the Sun's
gravitational pull.
So all of those
ways are to imagine
the extent of the solar system.
But they all kind of leave a
grey area for what is and what
is not in the solar system.
But my whole point
here, what I want to do
is start exploring a little
bit outside of the solar system
and just give you a
sense of the scale
as we just go to
the closest star.
So if we go right
over here, this
shows our local neighborhood
from a stellar point of view.
And even though these stars
look pretty big, if you actually
were to draw-- this is our
solar system right here.
And you might be saying,
oh, maybe that's the Sun.
No.
The Sun, if you were
to draw it here,
it wouldn't even
make up one pixel.
In fact, the entire orbit of
Pluto, everything inside of it,
still would not make up one
pixel on the screen right here.
What we see right here,
which is a radius-- it's
roughly a radius of about
give or take a light year--
this is roughly maybe the
radius of the Oort Cloud.
And we saw in the
last video, how
huge that was, especially
relative to the radius of
say Pluto's orbit, which
is roughly like that.
And that itself is a huge, huge
diameter or a huge distance
away from the Sun.
And that wouldn't
even make a pixel.
That wouldn't even make
a pixel on this diagram
right over here.
But just to give you an
idea of how far we are-- so
we're a speck of a speck
of a speck inside here,
of a pixel of a
pixel in the center
here-- to make it
from our solar system,
or in particular
from Earth maybe,
to the nearest star or
maybe the nearest cluster
of stars, the Alpha Centauri.
They're the nearest
cluster of stars.
There's three stars,
Alpha Centauri A,
which is the largest;
Alpha Centauri B;
and then, there's one
that you can't observe
with the naked eye,
Alpha Proximus.
Or I think it's
Proximus Centauri,
I think is what it's called,
not Alpha Proximus, Proximus
Centauri.
But that's a much smaller star.
But that's the
closest star-- well,
you could view it as this whole
cluster of stars right here.
And they're the closest-- is
about 4.2 light years away.
Or another way to
think about it,
if someone were to shine a
light on one of these planets,
and assuming that
light could get to us,
it would take 4.2
years to get to us.
Or if these guys just
disappeared or blew up,
we wouldn't know
it for 4.2 years.
And you might say, hey,
that's not too bad.
We should take a trip over
there and check them out,
see if there are any
other people there that we
can meet and exchange
technologies with, or whatnot.
But this is a huge distance.
Just this 4.2 light years is
an unbelievably ridiculous
distance.
And just to give you a
sense, the Voyager 1 and 2,
we talked about
in the last video,
and we can even see
how far they've gotten.
They've gotten to pretty
much to the heliopause.
These guys are traveling at
60,000 kilometers an hour,
which is the same thing as
17 kilometers per second.
If we were able to get up
to those type of velocities,
and these guys got up to
those type of velocities
by leveraging the gravitational
pull of some of the larger
planets to accelerate
and keep accelerating.
So this is a pretty hard
velocity to actually reach.
But if you were able
to reach that velocity
and go straight in the direction
of the direction of the Alpha
Centauri system, the
closest stars to Earth,
it would take you
80,000 years traveling
at the same velocity
as Voyager 1,
which is the fastest
of the Voyagers.
So it's a ridiculously
long time.
So we're going to figure out
some better way to do that.